members the press ladies and gentlemen
Prime Minister Prime Minister first of
all I really want to very sincerely
welcome you to Ireland and I look
forward to our conversation this morning
I think we can both agree that we have
much to discuss
first of all allow me to say that we
respect the democratic and sovereign
decision of the British people to leave
the European Union we meet this morning
at a point where it is stated intention
of the British government to lead the
European Union on the 31st of October
with or without a deal however in my
view the story of brexit won't end if
the United Kingdom ends the European
Union on the 31st of October or even the
31st of January there's no such thing as
a clean break or just getting it done
rather we'll just move on to a new phase
if there is no deal it'll cause severe
disruption for British and Irish people
alike not so much on the continent and
whatever happens we'll have to get back
to the negotiating table quite quickly
and when we do the first items on the
agenda will be citizens rights the
financial settlement and the Irish
border all issues which we had resolved
in the withdrawal agreement made we a
freed Assessor an agreement made in good
faith by 28 governments but if there is
a deal and I think it's possible we'll
enter talks on a future relationship
agreement between the EU and the UK it's
going to be very tough we'll have to
deal with issues like tariffs fishing
rights product standards state aid and
it will then have to be ratified by 31
Parliament's Prime Minister negotiating
FTAs with the EU in the US and securing
their ratification in less than three
years I think is going to be a Herculean
task for you but we do want to be your
friend and your ally your athina in
doing so and I think the manner in which
you leave the European Union will
determine whether that's possible I am
ready to listen to any constructive ways
in which we can achieve our agreed goals
and resolve the current impasse but what
we cannot do and will not do and I know
you understand this is agreed to
basements of illegal guarantee with the
promise our businesses need long-term
certainty and the people of this side
the north and south need to know that
their livelihoods their security and
their sense of identity will not be put
at risk as a consequence of praxis so
the stakes are high avoiding return to a
hard border on this island and
protecting our place in the single
market are the Irish government's
priorities in all circumstances we must
protect the peace and also the
burgeoning all Island economy and that's
why for us the backstop continues to be
a critical component of the withdrawal
agreements unless and until alternatives
are found but we are open to
alternatives but they must be realistic
ones legally binding and workable and we
haven't received such proposals to date
Prime Minister I know he's spoken twice
by phone already and I know we were very
very much a shared desire to see the
Northern Ireland institutions restored
and the tarnished and the Secretary of
State are already working closely on
that and the Good Friday Agreement is
the best example if every we needed it
to show that all foes can come together
to deal with the most intractable
problems and as Co guarantor of that
agreement I look forward to exploring
with you how working with the Northern
Ireland parties we can restore a parish
sharing and devolution I'm confident
that we'd be able to find some common
ground today and in doing so I'm
determined to defend the peace the old
Island economy and all that we hold dear
Prime Minister I know that you're an
admirer of the great Winston Churchill
as indeed am I and you've written
elegantly about him in your career in
the middle of the Second World War
Winston Churchill and the army chief of
staff Lord Alan Brooke made a long and
perilous journey across the Atlantic
from Washington by plane they reached
the coast of Ireland shortly after 4:00
a.m. an Alan Brooks description of their
first sight of Ireland is unexpectedly
poetic for a normally reserved military
man I'd like to finish by sharing that
with you beautiful moon shining on a sea
of clouds then out of the darkness dark
patches Lou
on the horizon which turned out to be
the north coast of mayo we soon struck
the coast only visible by moonlight PM
was thrilled as I was
I fear the Vista when he flew in this
morning into a very cloudy Dublin was
not quite a spectacular or thrilling but
you come nonetheless at a crucial point
in in our history and the relationship
between our two countries we may
sometimes differ but were bonded by our
shared past and our shared kinship and I
think we've a shared dream too one of
peace freedom and prosperity I look
forward to our discussions today and
invite you to make your marks thank you
very much teacher
Kaleo it's wonderful to be here in
Dublin and I thank you very much for the
very warm welcome you've you've given us
in spite of the slightly chilly weather
we're trying actually the media on
breathing as you all are this morning
yeah you and I first met a few years ago
when we jointly officiated at the San
Patrick's Day parade procession in
Trafalgar Square in London it was a
pretty joyous occasion and of course we
then celebrated the incalculable
contribution of the Irish community to
London and there in the vast crowds was
of course the living embodiment of one
of the densest and most intricate and
most vital relationships in the world
between any two countries and together
Lea we both recognize that our peoples
are the beneficiaries of the efforts of
our predecessors politicians and others
who put aside differences and who found
compromises and who took our countries
forwards together
in circumstances that are far tougher
than now and the results for both the UK
and Ireland are immense not just a
peaceful and open border
but an economic partnership by which we
in the UK eat I think 50 percent of all
the cheese and beef produced in Ireland
which is a lot and the very captain of
the world cup-winning English cricket
team was born in this city so I believe
our job now is to take that relationship
forward and to build on it we've got a
UK Island summit in in November I look
forward to that and then of course in
all the ways in which the UK and Ireland
work together around the world with
shared values and shared interests but
as you rightly say T shook before
November there are two tasks political
tasks that we simply have to do and we
must restore the government in Stormont
in Northern Ireland and I promise to
work with you on our shared objective
there and of course we must get brexit
done because the UK must come out on
October the 31st by October 31st or else
I fear that permanent damage will be
done in the UK to trust in our
democratic system and I know that brexit
was not to be perfectly frank a problem
that conundrum that Ireland wished for
and I think there are certainly
questions that we need to resolve and
there are three basic questions that we
have to answer for the sake of our
collective peace of mind can we ensure
that we continue to have unchecked
movement at the border of goods and
people and indeed cattle and I think the
answer is yes and as someone who went to
the border several times before the Good
Friday Agreement and shuddered to see
watchtowers on UK soil I can say now as
I've said many times before the UK will
never ever institute checks at the
border
and I hope our friends in the EU would
say the same can we uphold the Belfast
Good Friday Agreement in all its
particulars and again I say the answer
is yes and our commitment in the UK to
the peace process is unshakeable can we
protect the economic unity of the island
of Ireland and the gains that Ireland
has won through its membership of the EU
single market and again I think the
answer is yes and I think we can achieve
these things while allowing the UK to
withdraw hold an entire from the EU and
of course I acknowledge the complexities
involved and the symbolism and the
sensitivities evoked by the very concept
of a border but strip away the politics
and at the core of each problem you find
practical issues that can be resolved
with sufficient energy and a spirit of
compromise indeed the current treaty
must logically envisage that the
problems can be solved or the present
Protocol would never have been called a
backstop so I have one message that I
want to land with you today Leo and that
is that I want to find a deal I want to
get a deal like you
I've looked carefully at No Deal I've
assessed its consequences both our
country and and yours and yes of course
we could do it the UK could certainly
get through it but be in no doubt that
outcome would be a failure of statecraft
for which we would all be responsible
and so for the sake of business of
farmers and for millions of ordinary
people who are now counting on us to use
our imagination and creativity to
this done I want you to know I would
overwhelmingly prefer to find an
agreement our governments have spent
three years masticating this problem and
so I think it's time now to honor the
achievements of our predecessors who
tackled far worse problems by cracking
this one ourselves I won't say we can do
it all today but I do believe that a
deal can be done by October the 18th so
let's do it together thank you very much